let's have a gun debate
we have this story from the daily mail
gun wielding texas man who shot dead his
partner's ex-husband during furious
child custody rao will not be charged
after shooting his rule to be in
self-defense this is a very very
interesting story
so you can see here these two guys are
getting at it one guy's got a gun i
think it's a it's a uh i can't remember
what which kind of gun it is but it's a
nine millimeter a long gun of some sort
so i'll just give you the quick run down
and then we're gonna have this debate
because you know we were talking about a
bit about a bit before the show
so this dude is told you pick up your
son from your ex-wife at 3 15. he shows
up his ex-wife says no he says where is
my son she says i wanted to stay with
him longer so i'm not going to be giving
him to you and he says
you know in fact he basically is like
i'm here because the court says 3 15 he
is mine i come here 3 15. and then he
goes i'm going to drag you all you and
marie and so and so to court right when
he says this
his ex-wife's boyfriend comes out with
the gun
and comes on the porch and tells him to
get out the dad gets up in his face
doesn't use his arms and starts saying
oh are you gonna shoot me or something
like that the dude the gun fires one in
the ground
then they they
tussle
spin around the dad pushes the homeowner
a few feet off his porch and the
homeowner his wife's ex-boyfriend or his
wife's current boyfriend his ex-wife's
boyfriend immediately raises the rifle
and goes pop-pop towards his own house
hitting the dad twice killing him
instantly i believe it was instant
now uh the court is saying
he is not going to be charged with a
crime this one's tough because on the
letter of the law i'm torn on this one
was he acting in self-defense did he
have a right to shoot and kill this dad
who was coming to get his son
there's two ways i look at it the first
is
if the court tells me
be here and get your son you have to do
it it's custody like you haven't you
can't just ditch your kid and i show up
and they're like we're not giving the
kid up or telling you where he is and
then the dude walks out with a gun i'm
gonna be like you've kidnapped my child
and now you're threatening me with a
weapon i'm here under a court order
does that guy have a right to come out
with a gun
on that alone i'm like no and then not
only not only did he shoot and kill the
dad he pointed he shot he shot and
killed the dad towards his own house
that's one of the one of the rules of
gun safety know what is beyond your
target he could have shot his own
daughter because his daughter was
filming on the inside i couldn't really
tell when we watched the video maybe we
can watch it again i don't know where
you're planning on playing it i don't
know if we can
the daughters are in the house filming
out the window okay when he aims at him
and fires
his i can't tell if he's pointed at the
house or like it's pointed sideways
alongside the house well the guy was on
the porch so i'm pretty sure was at the
house and then the other problem was
that he shot into the ground to sort of
escalate the situation
and that's another no-no you don't fire
warning shots right like because you
don't know
what's where you're pointing i think
they knew each other the big dude was
abusive and the little guy was a big did
abusive i just have this isn't the
feeling i'm getting from this the big
guy was notably abusive that's why they
weren't together and the little guy
they knew each other and they hated each
other like clearly that's the vibe i was
because he went right at his face when
he came out with the gun they got right
in each other's face so
this is the problem i have with it
if
the the assumption of uh this guy's name
is william carruth who who shot and
killed chad reed
if you're in your house and you hear
fighting outside and you don't know
what's going on you have a right to keep
and bear arms your property i agree i
might get my gun as well people are
screaming i'll be like i don't know
what's going on but there might be
something bad happening you walk out
with your gun next thing you know a guy
gets up in your face that's screaming at
you
your first reaction is to fire into the
ground as like you can call an
escalation but if you have the option to
shoot the guy just got up in your face
maybe he just panicked and said i think
it's stupid to shoot in the ground might
do and then the guy grabs you you both
spin he pushes you back now he separated
you from your home
he could go in and harm your daughters
so you say
pop-pop
from that perspective i'm like i get it
we don't know what this guy knew but the
problem is man the the chad reed guy was
there legally to pick up his kid
and and it didn't even get there was not
enough time for him to even call the
cops apparently his new wife was already
calling the police about about the
argument when the arc when the yelling
happened and all the dad said was i'm
taking you to court
like not even a threat of violence and
the dude was out with a gun that this is
the challenge here because
if this dude william carruth knew why
the dad was there
you know and what was going on and came
out with his gun then i'd say charge him
but we can't assume he did know and he
can just be like i had no idea i heard
yelling and then it's like gun rights if
people are fighting on your property
you've got a right to defend it and like
you said and we don't know the history
of of these two guys i mean it's
possible that they've gotten into it
before he knows that this guy could
potentially come into the house and harm
his own children or or be looking for
this kid i mean we really don't know the
situation i'm also sympathetic to the
idea that if your
son is being withheld from you and you
have a right to be with your son then
parental instinct kind of kicks in and
like people will do anything to save and
help their children if they feel like
their children are being parentally
kidnapped so i understand that impulse
at a certain point though you have to be
smart enough to think
if i get myself involved in this
situation if i'm trying to grab this
guy's gun whatever
am i better off trying to be the better
person in retreat and potentially save
my life and get the court or the police
involved as opposed to trying to
start this fight that you're not going
to win because you don't also have a
weapon i mean it's this is it's a
difficult situation i don't really know
how like who is i met right here i mean
maybe they both were wrong in different
ways
but it's it's it's tough because like do
you send a guy to jail because he pulled
a gun on his own property because a guy
was yelling and then guy got in his face
but then i'm also thinking about if the
court orders someone to be there
and you come out like imagine if this
guy was a cop
who's instructed to be there by for law
enforcement purposes and you walk out
with your gun and the cop rushes you
i guess it's different my issue is just
like this dude
is trying to get his child
and when the wife is saying no and he's
like my kid's been kidnapped a dude then
comes out with a gun and at that point
i'm sure the dad's like you've kidnapped
my child and are threatening me with a
rifle with a long gun
like yo i'm surprised all he did was get
in his face well he also chest bumped
him which is aggressive
aggravated
and then he touches the gun too he
touches the hand that's on the gun which
basically is that dual possession at
this point like the ahmad arbory case
you know if you if you put your hand on
the weapon
not that's basically you're telling me
you're going to try and take it out of
my hands but not when they separate and
the dude goes pop-pop
the the the challenge is
do you really blame a dad
for getting in the face of a guy who
pulled who walked out with a gun when
his son's missing we got to talk about
what's legal and what's right that's the
thing like morally i don't think that he
was necessarily wrong but legally i
don't know that even if somebody has
your kid if you're allowed to go into
somebody else's home or try to grab that
like i don't know what the what the
legal situation is definitely not if
someone ever comes out on their front
porch with a rifle until you get off
their property get off their property
you go to the truck and you call the
police i mean you're you're asking for a
bad situation at this point not to
victim blame but
i think that's the best we can do to be
honest yeah that he should have
immediately backed up backed away and
said i'm getting the cops and the cops
would have come and he would have won
the fight exactly the cops would have
been like you are illegally withholding
a child you can't come out here with
that weapon go back in your house and
guess what he would have probably gotten
more custody of the kid if he had let
this play out because
they would have been accused of
endangering the child as well
yeah that split second of the dad
walking up to do with a gun you see him
snap when the guy comes out with the gun
he just goes right in his face like he
wants to fight that guy
man
yeah because if you're his kid it's his
son
like he doesn't even care about the kid
anymore he just wants to hurt the guys
that's this was like almost inevitable
to me the way that these guys were so
quick to go after each other let's get
to the dark part the dark part is the
mom has the kids living with the dude
who killed their dad
that's nuts apparently the kids were
like this is your favorite this is
almost like these kids are probably
gonna hear this show someday man at this
point it's like i'm sorry guys i mean
i'm here apparently the kids are like
really upset
as they should i gotta be honest if it
were me when i was a kid i would have
ran away yeah no joke i'm not gonna i
there's no way i'd live with the dude
who you know killed my dad well now we i
don't know enough about the conversation
because that guy might have been really
abusive but you said the kids i mean
it's still their dad no they're
apparently saying like it's your fault
you know wow
it's a crazy story this is america so
traumatic and
they're aware that kyle cruz shot and
killed their father in front of their
mother stepbrother and myself
a judge not ever denied the petition for
custody so this is um
this is the the
the dead father's new wife she was
trying to get custody and they were like
no you're not a blood relative
so the kids have to live with the dude
who killed their dad there's so much
with our
sister our custody system that is at
fault here too because
like that the default would be you have
to go to a blood relative is obviously
super problematic when you have family
members that are not fit to raise
children and i think it's really
unfortunate that you can't
assign to like a family friend or a
distant relative or something like that
in a situation like this
where
clearly these kids are living in a
traumatic potentially abusive situation
and yet you can't separate them for
whatever reason it's another reason why
i think uh for example like a lot of the
impulse to always give child custody of
the children a majority custody to the
mother is not
always the best policy either
so there's a lot that needs to be
reformed in that system maybe if they
had gotten this right from the beginning
this issue wouldn't have arisen to begin
with
man
i suppose the challenge is the moment
that
chad reed was on the porch with access
to the house and carruth was off the
porch with no access to the house that's
where it becomes justification because
now he's in between carruth and his
daughters yeah
or is it not justification if you're
just trying to get off my property
it might have been chad reed's daughters
i don't know
yeah it might have been his kids i'm not
entirely sure
yeah i guess there's some context we'll
need we would need to pull up
i think it i think it was his
it might have been his kids in there i'm
not entirely sure if it was um if it was
chad's daughters then that would have
made this guy with a gun more callous
about pointing it toward the house i
think that actually kind of makes sense
which i would think would then be an
argument for not ever leaving those kids
in his custody ever these poor kids now
i don't know where they end up so sad
yeah i think the kids inside the house
were chad reed's kids
not careless kids yeah oh my gosh
i'm not sure though that that's that's
important yeah a little bit
but he was only there to pick up his son
so again i'm not entirely sure it's been
a while we covered this when this we
talked about it when the story first
first broke but uh i wonder if people
are pointing it out no i don't know well
you guys comment you guys super chat and
then we'll get to it when we talk about
super chat so we can you know maybe
correct the record if we got if we if we
mix something up
crazy stuff man i'm curious yeah this is
a crazy philosophical conundrum i gotta
say thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you